so last week I went to New York to
announce that New France which is like a
digital conference that my production
studio rode away planet got investment
funding but I actually had a funny
experience on the plane right home when
the woman next to me said I'm really
sorry what these chips I normally don't
eat in front of people especially not
food this loud but I'm starving
and I laughed because whenever I eat
chips I think the exact same fucking
thing
and I realized exactly how stupid it is
to be self-conscious about things like
that because what kind of judgement are
we expecting Hey inconsiderate bitch
you're ruining my fucking story right
now I mean it's like when you're in
class and you have to go up and do a
presentation and you feel like everyone
is watching and judging your every move
when in reality everyone's kind of just
thinking about their own shit or like
when you go to a public restroom and
someone else is there and you are trying
to do your business as quietly as
possible although nothing's worse than
when you think someone's waving at you
so you wave back kind of awkwardly
and then surprise surprise they're
waving at the person behind you and you
casually try to play it off whenever you
feel self-conscious take comfort in the
fact that no one gives a fuck about you
seriously no one gives a shit once the
moment is over people mentally move on
it didn't really fucking matter all of
that negative insecure emotion could
have been directed towards paying
attention to someone else or getting to
know someone or observing the people
around you seriously it's a much better
feeling next time try it
tygris
I'm sorry I wanna help you get over
yourself that's nice
I'll see you next Monday stay awesome
awesome we're done